so I'm blonde today it's Veda which is a
video it's supposed to be vlog every day
in August but I was doing a video every
day in August because I don't
necessarily belong every day so it ought
to be fun just to chat with you guys
today and do a little monorover dance
for you I feel like you can be super
graceful on this thing hi whoa
do you guys lose behind making a video
hello oh boy I was just talking about
how you can be super graceful on this
thing I called it ice dancing you
guys'll say I can say hello
alright look who's here I'm wearing my
20th Pizza Hut I got monopoly I was just
talking to them about doing like a fun
little Friday video recap of everything
that I did this week so what I did I
fell down jenna fell down again what
else you do wants to do this in guiding
the number um it is cruising around I'm
having so much fun we did a shoot all
day today and the only thing I could
think about was I'm near Jenna's house
and you know what's Jenna's house this
thing yeah I figured that's why you came
over
no one hangout with my sister I want to
hang out with my sister you're making me
dizzy so yeah if you guys haven't eaten
do videos that I posted this week we're
doing Veda so it's basically we're all
vlogging every day we are making videos
every day it's from Final sitars yeah
you guys did so this week I made a poop
emoji and go check that out
me and Jenna unboxed the wooly Yoshi
amiibo super cute we also did to say
anything challenge do you remember that
that was this week yeah we had Matt's
birthday party match Amuro you had a
birthday last night yeah haven't you
guys really nice people oh yes and what
was that vlog oh I had a some shoots
Francesca do my makeup is a little
before and after I made salmon fish
and then yesterday's video we went out
to the beach we wrote hoverboarding how
do you say it hover up goober hover
cougar now hover hover yeah guys instead
of playing Monopoly I know we can do
what's that
we can listen to my audio book are you
doing movie I'm gonna take those things
away from you yes did you dent the table
no I actually did not I don't know I'm
the new so if you guys want to do
something fun this weekend if anybody
listens to my audio book you could
actually get it for free a free download
on audible if you go to audible.com
slash Ida scene you can get a 30-day
free credit actually just downloaded it
because I've been so nervous to hear
myself read my book I just downloaded it
I'm Michael horn you couldn't say there
was celerity familial Familia rightful
mil familial arity familiar Larry from
middle urania Larry okay I'm calm /i
justine if you guys want to get it for
free if you haven't got your free trial
yet mat you should check it out i think
you'll love it
well whoa whoa whoa what else are we
gonna do they watch you wipe out how
about some how deep is your love that
she means what a great song i only be
responding to some comments from this
video and all of the ones this past week
so go check out the audiobook leave me
some comments and i'm gonna go
I guess played Monopoly yes I get then
our queen dinner watch me fly you can
only eat it you played it off hold on
good time now watch me whip now watch me
nae nae now watch me whip look at so
much meaning
see what good job allow me with my eyes
you now on me today
now watch me whip what no I love this
thing so much I hate it I hate it
honestly I made fun of everyone who had
these and I was like you're so silly
you're so silly and then I hopped on one
that was like my life history visa okay
I'm done now okay I'm sweating